Solve for x.
We have 8 times the
quantity 3x plus 10
is equal to 28x
minus 14 minus 4x.
So like every equation
we've done so far,
we just want to isolate
all of the x's on one side
of this equation.
But before we do
that, we can actually
simplify each of these sides.
On the left-hand
side, we can multiply
the quantity 3x plus 10 times 8.
So we're essentially
just distributing
the 8, the distributive
property right here.
So this is the same thing
as 8 times 3x, which is 24x,
plus 8 times 10, which
is 80, is equal to--
and over here, we have
28x minus 14 minus 4x.
So we can combine the
28x and the minus 4x.
If we have 28x minus
4x, that is 24x
And then you have the
minus 14 right over here.
Now, the next thing we
could-- and it's already
looking a little bit suspicious,
but just to confirm that it's
as suspicious as
it looks, let's try
to subtract 24x from both
sides of this equation.
And if we do that, we see that
we actually remove the x's
from both sides of the equation
because we have a 24x there,
and we have a 24x there.
You might say,
hey, let's put all
the x's on the left-hand side.
So let's get rid of this 24x.
So you subtract 24x
right over there,
but you have to do it to
the left-hand side as well.
On the left-hand side,
these guys cancel out,
and you're left with just
80-- these guys cancel out
as well-- is equal
to a negative 14.
Now, this looks very bizarre.
It's making a statement that
80 is equal to negative 14,
which we know is not true.
This does not happen.
80 is never equal
to negative 14.
They're just inherently inequal.
So this equation right here
actually has no solution.
This has no solution.
There is a no x-value that will
make 80 equal to negative 14.